would you please leave the building via
the news to vailable exit there is one
Forex in this room if you need to
evacuate the room do so by the glass
door to the external fire escape
staircase
please hold both handrails in case the
stairs of wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs would they
please allow others to exit the room
before they go to the for escape door
but they cannot be given assistance our
assembly point will be in the public
carpark of the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please know that this meeting will be
audio recorded and can I please remind
you to switch off your mobile phones or
turn them to society thanks everyone and
what do you think of welcome and welcome
to a member of the public right
apologies for absence I know that George
iron who's not too pretty another moment
so I'll give his apologies I don't
believe there are any others make sure
there's no other members attendee now a
minutes of the meeting held on the 5th
of December is it your wish I sign them
as a true copy great rude or anything
arising from those minutes not mentioned
elsewhere in the agenda anybody wants to
discuss ok any declarations of interest
please now if anything should arise
during the meeting please declare and
then we make sure it's minuted right
masses referred by some five matters
referred to the executive and reports
from other committees there are none so
the first item is the quarter three
financial management performance report
this I think it speaks for itself
well yeah yeah so this is the quarter
three and the financial management
performance report up Thanks and it sets
out the revenue position as well as
capturing position and the
performance patience of the year today
so in summary the revenue position is
projecting an under spend for the
current battery year of just over a
million pounds which is obviously that
is significant and very compared to our
original budget of about nine million
pounds so just over 10% else has been
discussed at previous meetings the key
driver of the on suspend is salaries and
so we've had a higher number than normal
of vacancies throughout the year and
coupled with the policy we had at the
start of the year haunting all Bank
place six months that's driven quite
significant staff and under spend this
financial year yeah just over seven
hundred thousand pounds projected as I
said as I've said at previous meetings
we're not expectin side level of salary
underspend next year we have taken a few
of the Pais which are not required and
out of the budget next year which is
helping to deliver some savings for next
year and in addition we've had quite a
few posts recruited to in the past few
months I believe we're only holding a
couple of posts actively vacant at the
moment so we're not expecting that lemon
one to spend to be a co next year in
addition there's a couple of other
drivers awfully under spend on the
revenue position so planning feeing
comes
projected to be about 150,000 pounds
higher than budgeted form and also on
the housing benefit and subsidy playing
we've purchased about one hundred and
fifty thousand pounds of our suspended
them was originally budgeted for as well
so they're really the key the key
drivers for the underspend is financial
year one of the recommendations in the
report is that we actually transfer six
hundred thousand pounds of that under
spend into any amount reserve at
year-end and that would be to support
delivery of the local plan and joint
strategic plan work over the next five
years and there is some thinking behind
that in that we've actually taken out
about 150,000 pounds per annum annual
revenue budget in from 1920 onwards
obviously that subject to a pretty
hopeful council next week but by taking
out that revenue saving annually we
obviously deliver an ongoing revenue
saying but at the same time we would
know there will be some cost associated
with delivering the plan work and
Reserve will give us the flexibility
because we don't know exactly how that
will be profiled over the next five
years so that would leave a residual
protection under spend of about four
hundred and fifty thousand pounds
currently at year-end and we would then
make recommendations up in court for us
to where we would laugh at year end so
that's all I was going to say on the
revenue ting position in terms of their
capital program that's also set out in
their report there is a bit of slippage
compared to the q2 position so we're
currently projecting to spend 2.7
million of an original 3.3 million
pounds budgets and however most of that
will be requested to be paid for it
again as part of the year the year-end
process so it's more about profiling and
that we haven't managed to spend all of
the money quite as quickly as we might
approach in some in some cases but the
majority of the capital program is is
projected to be on traffic on a tree in
I think the performance indicators
probably speak for themselves so unless
anyone's got any specific questions
around those I just let you die just
like yourselves but if anyone's
just one point I might make if I may sir
you know I mean you've I think you've
already mentioned it is it does say
within risk implications about where
there are delays to implementation of
projects related to time limited grants
but I think we're all forced to actually
achieve those are we not yes that's
referring to where we get like Ron's
from central government that have
specific conditions attached to them and
we have to account for those in a
specific way we can't obviously use them
for other purposes so yeah the majority
of those are projected to be used for
the purpose intended but it yeah if not
we we have to be very pay them all
potentially awesome to be going forward
yes so all we want all oh yeah I can get
back I mean this quite apps might have
quite a number of small individual
online so I can probably provide more
detail if you like that I think the
majority of those reviewing you know
okay well I think you know this is what
we have to be careful of them
concentrate on to make sure we you know
make the most of the monies of the
grants that we had there because you
wouldn't want to lose them plus whole
point or making yes I mean so in the
housing ones for companies it's very
sort of cooperative you keeping on track
and making sure that we use advise of
those grants meaningful okay thank you
Ian please don't say rubbish in person
no it's it's a good thing to say but we
had this residual amount and especially
the fact of the six thousand six hundred
thousand which is going towards planning
to support the local plan because you
know it's been a big concern to me with
regard to getting that local plan out I
am very much aware of other districts
and boroughs especially within our
southeast area who have been in some
kind of special measures so to speak or
or the ministry is seriously looking at
them
I have no wish and I think everyone
around here has no wish for us to be
under such forward inspection so I think
that is most welcome to have the
transfer of that funds specifically for
that times thank you and I believe
that's just a biblical plan the Jordan
strategic plan and related development
plan documents over the next five years
so you know that money's got to achieve
quite a lot if you like so this is what
we've managed to put that aside to cover
it absolutely someplace just as a
formality to say there's a portfolio
Tottenville
fully endorse the interpretation of the
figures and the information that that
you've been given and I think as council
waters just said the the transfers of
the MDF is is particularly important
because good planning of what goes where
when how and the strategic facilities
that we have within our district are key
to our ongoing successful future and it
has to be said we are a successful
Authority just recently again we've been
named as a one of the more desirable
places to live so I think the steps that
we've taken in the past which we're
looking to repeat with our detailed
planning our good management of finances
and planning for the future I'm gonna
put us in good stead I think the return
there his local place is near LDF is it
he's gonna be redundant although he's
been able ta say it is jog and it's
whatever absolutely whatever bid face
what the appropriate acronym is at the
time isn't it really but I think it goes
with the blue colour of the government
of a particular time Mike you wanna say
yeah just really I had to use the big
word the bricks it word it looks
increasingly like
have an ideal scenario situation is
there any concerns budgetary wires that
might be coming come forward from that
or is it just we just don't know I think
the answer is we don't we don't know I
know at least specifically
yeah it's just very difficult to tell at
this stage but obviously it's something
we just keep on watching watching
briefed on and if there's any specific
things that emerge we would obviously
we've got some reserves and the we could
potentially use there was any
concessions that are over and we're not
anticipating there's any specific
revenue passes other than this area
we've been awarded a small grant by and
central government to help us with an
administration one yes so yeah we will
be in receipt of an extra client as part
of the local governments which were
meant to help us them manage any sort of
one of administration cost associate
degree tink you can what yeah new order
contain let's thank you very much again
just bringing on that subject council
stepped over right we've got to practice
yeah I think we need to emphasize the
this is going to be a council that it's
going to be open for business because
whatever happens we're going to be a
trading notion going out through the
world but we need to encourage two-way
trade through the world to make sure we
have investment in and make sure we have
exports out and I think that's very
important you know that we recognize
where we want to be coming forward thank
you okay so I think we have a very good
report from you know would you take
encouragement from what's going on there
so no thank you knowing me and your team
probably would work that you've done and
there it and
the rest of the offices as well with
it's no question that's well done so
thank you for that there's a decision
being recommended presumably that's
going to go on to a recommendation okay
okay so the decision that we're making
then is to note the call to three
revenue budget capital positions set out
in sections three and four and a
detailed in appendices appendices one to
four to approve the transfer of six
hundred thousand of budgets from the in
year underspend
to the local development fund to reserve
the right Israel to go through quite
right sorry apologies for that a local
development fund reserve to increase the
funds for planning policy work to
support the delivery of the local plane
joint strategic plan and related
development plan documents over the next
five years this would leave a residual
projected under spend of 450,000 in
2018-19 and to also know the latest
addition of the council's key
performance indicators as shown in
appendix five members of Greenwood thank
you very much indeed
so there's item six item seven one get
to it is the award at the end of a
community graph bless you
they've our mental services which i
think is a bit learn on brainer i think
if you don't say anything about this
okay it is so for the summer four and a
half thousand we can get a probably
5,000 wrong so you know as I said I
think that's a good deal
congratulations on our grant seeker the
only other thing I would say about that
is you know is it time limited it is
time limited but there is usually
limited to a year but I mean certainly
we have everything in place to ensure
these it's deliverable absolutely
anticipation being scrutinized in motion
almost straight to one side
okay smashing any other points well done
to your team
thank you comes so members agree that
the recommendation thank you as item
eight is the Heritage growth project and
this is to note the arrangement makes a
school a long term visitor potential
policy island including an event in May
20-22 the council's discovered 2024 I
know George was going to speak on this
before she's not very well but I think
the report speaks for itself I don't
know if you want to add anything at all
no I just think I welcome the the 2020
festival I think it's a fantastic
opportunity for us as a district I'm
part of the steering group meeting on
Monday very much looking forward to
taking this forward it's going to be
fantastic for this trip
I guess the only thing I would say is we
just need to be mindful if we do need to
make any further budget reinvestment
into the 2020 festival at the moment is
majorities officer time which is finding
these early stages I know that we are
we're relying on parishes to get heavily
involved to understand that but I still
would I guess put to the group for
discussion doing it to the cut line in
the budget next year to make sure that
this festival is the best
okay make sure the budget is there for
it yeah okay but again I think it's a
lot long-term I think as the decision
says itself
he's securing the long term is the
potential of what's he on yeah right so
when you hear things thank you I just
wondered how far are we spreading this
are we trying to go as far as you can
rather than just keeping within our own
area are we actually looking outside
world white because I mean warsi island
in itself is a world heritage site or
likely to be made money if it isn't one
wedding and and maybe we should be
spreading ourselves as far as we can to
bring that interest in because you know
as I said just previously you know what
we need to be looking at ourselves as
open for business and bringing in
investment and not only they trying to
encourage what we're doing here for
export because we're going to have to be
a trading nation whichever way you look
at it and we need to be up the front
making sure look what we're doing this
problem yes thank you chair so the HMS
Beagle is the project and 2020 is the
year of Mayflower 400 so it's the old
ships
we've heart as part of all this SS
subscription we can access European
funding to attractor an American market
to the UK for 2020 and Mayflower for
hundred islands beat your sales from
Plymouth in in 1918 3100 clearly they
keep a flower sight
we're also stitched into the Essex 2020
festival of science technology
engineering arts and mathematics which
is aligned to a are you hosting the
British Science Festival in 2020 so
clearly alignment both with Darwin with
Fitzroy and with the engineering project
in fact all of the islands so we're
going with very much tied in with that
this is shown on the tempo anymore I
just asked you did make sure you there
isn't there's hopefully not a question
okay that funnies been in place for a
while
oh really preparation nothing they will
charge okay okay that's brilliant
but new members will recall I think I
think it was last year we had a Chinese
delegation come forward to visit
Wallasey Island because it was of the
example of what can be achieved when
you're creating a wetland such as that I
think the Chinese project was much
larger but having said that what we have
a policy is that I think one of the
largest in Europe coming forward so we
should be really proud of it
Simon you wanted to say all night and
father we've got the resource
implications and the capital investments
there I'm clear clearly they say as you
said this is a big project with lots of
different people getting involved and
we're playing our part without it
wanting what wanting to request anything
that's bureaucratic and not going to add
to it I think it is worth somewhere
along the line just standing back and
quantifying what our or other resource
will be whether it be officer time
whether there doesn't need to be money
so that we can ensure that were
conscious of what putting to it and if a
line needs to go into the budget or a
reserve needs to be accessed we're aware
of that as far in advance
absolutely so at the last meeting of the
organizing committee were very much
discussing the parameters of the
festival of the role of the organising
committee on what we want to do the
agenda for Monday's very much about
crystallizing that out and preparing
documentation which I invented one that
we can agree and the idea being then
that that there'll be another tourism
for importantly in April but we actually
say well this this is the programme
these these this is essentially the
event organizers pack if you want to
organise an event here's your pack go
away into it but you need to tell us so
that we can curate the programme we've
got branding and marketing associated
with that so so there the idea being
that we will try and defray costs as
much as possible through the use of
volunteers what this paper doesn't yet
this this paper deals with the capital
works necessary to put to allow it works
to take place on site it doesn't deal
with the actual delivery of the event
itself which John and I are working up
and we we believe that we should be able
to throw a combination of cash and
in-kind sponsorship be able to cover the
vast majority of a couple with
essentially charging an entrance fee but
those that business case called come
back to an executive for approval before
the thylacine it off okay thank you very
much anything else
members oh so here's your lunch isn't it
just a question just saw me struggling
the rules you thought that the Royal
Geographical Society
how much involvement have we helped with
them so we are torn and I put together a
list of potential sponsors we haven't
made the geographical society
specifically we've tended to we've gone
for Natural History Museum and
Sedgwick Museum and Thomas not all the
others the other kind of Darwin and the
Darwin and Fitzroy related I'm specifics
but yes we could approach those probably
be really interested listen you can know
what we gotta do is were simply going to
count what I can to be perfectly honest
and see who we can get interested in the
project that's it go out there without
captain eating in front of us absolutely
and so we should so thank you for all
the work that's been done on this there
are no other comments members agree the
decision thank you so item nine which is
the awarding of the voluntary sector
grants is very good that we can still
give these grants across I don't know if
you want to say yes German so this
report outlines the RDC community grant
scheme where we are supporting a third
sector working in the community I think
we can be proud by planning support for
the voluntary and community secretary
March hood last year 15 organizations
across the district benefited from a
small grant scheme we've got also
analyzed the proposed stops and funding
for abs which is 15 km total the small
board skin will have no capital funding
this year only revenue is we give
applicants more flexibility when
hospital support enhanced existing
services and will fit better with our
push to fit better with our such age of
priorities in essence we need to get
away from repairs and maintenance grants
the maximum application for each
organization is limited to a thousand
dollars so the grants this year will
have a focus on health and well-being
has that 9422 in the report especially
looking to reduce that was a BCT
overweight teenis as well as improvement
mental health and well-being and
supporting people to leading end of
lives
so in summary I'm very proud of that
she's accountable to continue this one
part scheme
click over the last few years and I'm
sure it'll continue to be sing thank you
so it's not just about working the
community it's about the health and
well-being of population absolutely yeah
which is good anything to come from I
think thank you something you want to
say so yes
Oh item 4.3 it's got myself as chairing
the member advisory Truman I've enjoyed
doing that that task further up for a
number of years the are reflecting a
number of the groups the third that
apply as are fairly small small groups
of firms more grants don't necessarily
have the experience of bigger
organizations in putting grant
applications together so sometimes the
the pattern when it means needs a little
bit more community information about how
these groups operate and I think
counselor Webb with with his particular
portfolio is is probably a little bit
better informed on the impact of the
groups within the community and the
impact that the grants might have so I'd
be happy to move that council aware
chairs the member advisory group for
determining the king of the myself thank
you are there be any chiptune so there's
not this again so we did I haven't
thanked you yet Jim just just just to
out it wouldn't need a further check but
it might be the counselor Smith needs to
be involved in the very final sign-off
based on the constitutional for name
yeah but the may need that doesn't yeah
yeah yeah thank you I just asked a
question in regards to the world
the allocation yes they're kind of a pop
funding is there is there way in which a
percentage that is put forward obviously
you're giving a grown to expect to have
them to raise money and you're putting
another percentages because I noticed
the thing towards a minivan you know I
don't have a problem and then to the
cost of a new plywood cladding for
Windows these were the latter two on on
the last page the bumpers 505 5100 and
the other one was five thousand of
rationale it's entirely dependent on
what they apply for sometimes you're
trying to make the money go round as
many groups as you possibly can and so
you determine that you can part fund an
application rather than for the cotton
but to give flexibility it's not set in
stone it's not all or nothing okay thank
you fine yeah it's a question of are
many times with regards to we've got CIP
and what have you that we support do we
document at do we show a monetary value
towards what we give them free of charge
I in the office space car parking spaces
that sort of thing because that is part
of what we're planting to them there is
a cost involved with that I've seen that
exercise done okay and it's have to tell
you I couldn't point you to the figures
about sailing Guardians okay I think
that should be shown as part of what the
monetary value we do give those
organizations I think that needs to be
part of the documentation yeah that's
pretty this way if it was that if it was
something that was given to you as part
of a salary
lmd as a part of your salary good yes
you know this
it certainly doesn't affect the
organization's it's just nice to know
you know the sort of total we feel like
that we're granting over any in its
fullness going forward are there any
other questions please members agreed
the decision right so that was item at
nine now i some standalone be neutral
because the last item is not available
so we'll leave there and that's it thank
you very much you did close the meeting
[Music]